I kind of get it from a business
standpoint if they're fill-in the rooms
I did a gig in in Arizona once and they
had a daytime gig booked from a YouTube
influencer they packed this place out at
11:00 a.m. with like 12 year old kids as
fans was his name Bert Kreischer yes it
was it was a Bert Kreischer day show
shirt off it was a crop top he wore a
halter berth does those day shows do
radio and then I'll do a show it like
noon for people that don't have jobs
yeah it's like work call in sick to work
or sometimes he call it something like
that yeah
call in sick to work day yeah so funny
that ladies he's looking slim yeah that
is slim for Bert that's only like
nineteen months pregnant yeah that's a
protrusion and it's hard eight-year-old
in the belly year-old inside of them
that's to take his shirt he takes his
shirt off in the oh our now every time
yeah I used to take a shirt off only in
the main rooms like hmm now now I
decided no more of that does it come off
all every show we set right one stage he
takes his shirt off what did he decide
when that happens I wonder like me a
moment just right that's how you do it
pre pre mic grabber grabs a mic well his
body is a source of pride he enjoys what
the fruits of his labor yeah and his
appetite for indulgence I don't know if
it's a body as much as it is a building
it's a body people know what's his body
they know he's the party animal and they
go all right fuck yeah he's fun it is a
lot of fun it's AB article that was
written about that like talking about I
was reading this guy was like talking
about how hilarious it was it's a party
it definitely is absurd II he is an
animal and sometimes you know I mean
there's the opposite where people are
just kind of quiet on stage laugh just
by taking off my shirt I think I'd go
for it why not start off with it but now
the problem is I think Burt owns it
which is weird you know Mike he's like
you think he should have some like a
little bit of a feeling about it no like
he owns it like if I just wanted to go
up and take your shirt off people go
what do you copy
it's a good point he's the only one
doing it he's the only comic D robing
every time but there's some weird ones
like that Bobby Bobby Lee takes his
pants off I mean I've seen that that
weenie weenie a few times winking at me
from the green rooms of the comics you
should probably not tell people that
stop doing it people probably get mad
now get madder throat yeah you can't you
can't not do it they're like take off
the shirt do the jump on am on stage
tackle them yeah yeah but I mean there's
there's a couple dudes who go clothes
clothes off their pants and their shirts
but we're that that's Bert's thing yeah
it is weird
you're right though if anybody else were
to do it they would know that that was a
Burt situation there was another one
like that that we were just talking
about the other night at the comic store
like how crazy does that someone like
took over like a thing yeah a stand-up
comedian remember I wanna know what it
is well there's like a cup there's a
comic in New York or does it snaps like
a snap every time it you know Frasier
Smith I love watching fraser-smith when
he's like come on people these are jokes
and he likes it's like it's like a
timekeeper I like that right yes in
rhythm yeah it keeps you in rhythm it's
it's musical up there sometimes if it's
going let it go as well it's weird how
people can become like a thing like this
is the guy who talks about food I know I
was thinking about that like how what
what what comes first in that scenario
doesn't naturally evolve or does it
happen once and then the person builds
around it because it's a crutch mmm
there's there's a fine line between the
art in the marketing exactly yeah and in
who you know do your thing like it's a
short life why not find that little
niche that works for you and fucking
make that money and have fun and bring
some joy to people who gives a fuck I
have a problem with people who talk shit
about people going after what they're
doing and finding a little trick to it
who cares people get angry if they get
tricked God yeah that's true that's true
fucking tricky you can't believe this
shit
[Laughter]